okay it's uh 9 45 going to open up the
executive session for the house election
law committee real brief we're going to
do the Pledge of Allegiance
representative and you're joining us you
okay
um we're going to open up the executive
session for cacr relating to the New
Hampshire presidential variety primary
providing that the New Hampshire
president's primary will be the first
presidential primary over presidential
election cycle uh with that I'll
recognize myself for a motion I will
move the cacr be inexpedient to
legislate is there a second
I'll second it second of our
representative Lane
um seconded by representative Lane is
there discussion on the cacr
hearing none uh the clerk called the
rolling please call Representative
quaylee first okay because he is our
ranking member for who's here
representative qualey
uh the motion is to uh in expedient to
representative Purdue and O'Brien
oh oh I'm sorry
representative Ammon
yes
representative uh Ankerberg
is he here
absent
representative Burnham yes
representative Kennedy
representative uh POTUS
representative wood yes
representative Wayne
yes
representative Hamlet yes
representative Bay yes
representative Granite yes
representative Grill yes
um New Hampshire is number one DJ
representative vote Yes
and uh the DJ of our committee in a
sense representative Barry well chair
votes yes
without the itl motion carries 19-0 I'll
be closing the executive session for
cacr9 and once again my apologies to the
committee are my intention was to exec
this at the session that we're supposed
to have on Thursday which we didn't
happen so I apologize for dragging you
here again
um my sincere apologies and with that we
are closing uh I'm sorry yes ma'am yes
representative
oh yeah well that was yes the objection
consent calendar
uh it's on consent
um
with that closing the executive session
and I'll see some of you for
the Starbucks is open on uh oh whoa you
said that with the hot mic you see you
drink
thanks for being here today day and
thank you members of the interested
public we appreciate your presence and
I'm gonna
start today's
election law committee subcommittee work
session
and our topic is discussing
ways in which we can improve our
campaign Finance system and
I think our mutual objective is to find
the areas we can agree on
oh thank you again for being here would
someone
care to open the discussion with what's
oh yeah before before I begin before I
begin I would just uh I'm going to
schedule two more meetings today
one for two weeks from today
and another for two weeks after that
and I'm hoping that one of those
meetings will
include a representative from the
Attorney General's office to talk to us
about enforcement of campaign Finance
law
uh hope maybe the next meeting but one
if you need that Jerry sir which which
oh
yeah
okay thank you
uh and I think on the uh the second of
those two meetings uh whichever one is
open
it
I think it'd be a good time to start
discussing uh you know see what the
areas of agreement are among us
and maybe start outlining what a report
would look like I'm not look looking to
truncate this process prematurely but
we've had several meetings now and I
think it's probably time to start
thinking about the end product that
sounded oh that sound good to you guys
two more meetings scheduled
two weeks from today another two weeks
after that that would be the
13th and the 27th thank you
representative Ward
and one of those meetings hopefully
we'll hear from the Attorney General's
office and the other will start planning
what our end product will look like
thank you
so that said
uh representative that sounds like a
good a good plan and I really could we
send something official and maybe urgent
to the AG's office because if they came
on the 13th that would set us up
to kind of Define our tasks with more
precision
and be more productive on our second
meeting on the 27th I agree with that
and representative Lane has been working
heroically
to
get their attention and I'm sure they
are very busy with with uh things they
need to get done also but
uh
thank you representative Lane for your
efforts
and and
um
you know one of my goals is over that
that sort of span of time between now on
the 27th to come up with suggestions
that would address most or all of the
problems identified in the Secretary of
State's memo and I sort of just listed
those in a very mechanical fashion in
that handout that I just passed around
um
but uh there's kind of a very I think
very it's persuasive that the the things
identified as problems really are
problems that don't involve
um political the kind of political
judgment the Democrats and Republicans
often
that generate disagreement
um that that are more administrative
problems that that you know good clear
legislation could solve I think that's
what the Secretary of State's memo
really that was a great service to us
and so I think yeah well you know we we
should set as our task solving most of
those problems
right what one example I don't know if
it's in your list I haven't had a chance
to read it yet but the the use of
Fiscal Agent Financial agent Treasurer
with regard to candidates and candidate
committees
uh I can't see a reason why we can't
settle on a single term there
single a single phrase to use right so
thank you
yes there's another there's another just
uh maybe process or anything
representative Lane
did you pass around your definitions to
everybody so maybe the next meeting if
people have
um this this is just represent I'm
speaking for you representative Lane
this is her you know not her best and
final effort it was just kind of an
initial effort to create uh to solve
some of the problems that are current
definitions create by by writing new and
better ones but maybe everybody could
take a look at those between now and the
next meeting and
um and come back with suggestions
um so that we can make a little we we
can lay down that Foundation the
foundation of good definitions sooner
rather than later
I can I can send them out electronically
to the folks if that helps
oh yeah yeah that would definitely help
all right
all right to get an electronic copy and
uh representative mirrorhead would you
send one of your list also
yeah I've uh
I started a similar list I don't
consider it ready but I was I was a
little hesitant but yeah
but by our next meeting I'll have
I figured this way everybody can look at
them and say no that doesn't make sense
so if we're going to do it this way then
we shouldn't do it you know because the
hardest thing I'm having trouble with is
candidate and candidate committee and is
a can't do we do we require the
candidate to have a candidate committee
and if we don't
um then how to how do we work that
filing or just do we just have a
separate we have a political committee
and a candidate committee and a
candidate and those are the only three
things we have I I don't know I'm trying
to
figure that approach out well I've been
thinking about that also and
I do think
enabling uh particularly a state
representative candidate to run as a
candidate without having to form a
committee reduces the the burdensiveness
of the process because for State Rep
not as expensive or complicated uh
with regards to the campaigning and if
we make it too burdensome for what's
typically a small effort compared to you
know the higher offices then it
increases the barrier to entry which we
don't want to do
we want to keep the barrier to entry for
candidates
at some level so we don't exclude people
is what I think
and as far as candidates and candidate
committees in that state rep context
I've been thinking about this as well I
don't know why we couldn't just have the
same set of requirements for both in
terms of deadlines for reporting
and for that matter for contribution
limits or
one of the areas that this right you
think in the same way
we'll have to look at it and look for
pitfalls in that but
so far I'm not seeing any
uh
one area that's different between the
two
were
I remember right limits on how much a
candidate contributes to somebody else
another effort versus how much
I'm not seeing why those should be
different at this point
that's just an example of something we
could bring into
are we fairly decided that we want to
put all of them no longer have
exploratory
campaign
and either transition or whatever they
were just going to have one kind of
cycle and the limits are going to be on
that cycle
yeah that was one of the items on my
list which okay I need to refine a
little bit okay but
uh
yeah basically
I'm thinking I'm thinking we should
Define what we mean by election cycle
and we've discussed this in previous
meetings I'm thinking it the election
cycle as defined should start the day
after the general election
and go through the day of the general
election
again have the conversation because I
don't think representative Barry was
here last week last time we met
representative Barry wasn't here so I
wanted him to see yeah he'll be here in
a couple of minutes by the way okay but
uh
another item on my on my list Common
Center reporting deadlines for
candidates and candidate committees
uh that the list of Secretary of State's
office Mr Fish gave us
or the table showing
the different reporting deadlines
uh
um the only thing that I had about that
is that some of these particularly the
super Pacs
they start spending like right before
the sometimes right before the election
or get really intense so some of those
reporting dates may not capture those
before the election so so I can't
remember if we have we have
a reporting date not long before the
election and then again right after
so
just as a way of discussing it for the
packs that don't really start spending
money until say a month or 45 days
before
if we have them on a regular cycle
do we put it close enough or some places
tie it to when they make the expense I
think even now our own one says
expenditures over a certain amount you
have to immediately report them or
within three days or something
so but then we start differentiating and
again it makes it more complicated but
so I'm just throwing it out there no I
understand I I was actually thinking
specifically of the distinction between
a candidate running as a candidate
and as his or her own Fiscal Agent for
example
and a candidate committee
and I think a candidate committee has
already has already defined differently
and
and I think we've discussed this also I
was also thinking right right now we
have an election cycle
it uh
I think it I'm not did we find a
definition of that term in the statutes
does it exist
no it's kind of I think it's
most people assume it's what we were
just talking about which is the day
after the general election until the
through the day of the next general
election
but the election cycle has I think three
phases right there's free filing there's
the primary
uh period and then there's the general
uh
when the secretary of state was here
with Mr Fitch I think
he was floating the idea of having you
know the the date that a candidate files
his candidates his or her candidacy
would be the date on which they
officially become a candidate
and I was thinking that made some good
sense
I don't like it because oh there's a lot
of campaign campaign Finance going on
before you announce I mean
and so you would lose all of that you
would lose all of that transparency
so somebody's really smart you can you
donate you get all your donations and
spend as much as you want before which
you can do and and then but you don't
have to declare it
and you're not really a candidate so
what so when I I floated a balloon and
what I drafted that it's like when you
start acting like a candidate and when
you make get contributions and you get
dispersed and you start making
disbursements that's when you're a
candidate
and then you have and I guess then you
I haven't completely thought that
through yet what my thinking was more
along the lines we do have
in the statutes that when you
put out advertising
in intended to
promote or elect someone as a candidate
and
maybe we can work it around that I don't
it does offer a broader definition
candidate than just when you announce
because you know even in my small
on an unopposed one I was running well
before I filed well and with a two-year
term for any office you're really always
running campaign is never over right
right really if you're intending to run
again
uh you did say something a bit ago about
uh
removing some committee types and one of
the ones you mentioned was the
dude I remember that did I hear that
right we talked about
um
expiratory
um then the campaign and then is there
there's three different kinds I think
right now in the three three of them is
it transition or inauguration oh that's
the
it's the one in the
so when we were talking before we were
saying let's just say for instance I
think one of the it's 5 000 for each
category so in other words just make it
fifteen thousand for the whole shebang
so you can give 15 000 from the time
you know that candidate is a candidate
and if you want to do it early grade if
you don't you can wait but I think
rather than have all these you know
it's not a lot I don't know how many
I'm trying to find it in the statute
yeah
that's going to take some more thought
on my part yeah it's primary yeah it's
in 6644.
so
it's
the maximum amount contributed during
exploratory than during the primary and
then during the election
and so the idea is that you can
um and I think this was representative
Barry's suggestion is that then the
whole the total then for a candidate
um and for a non-candidate so and then
they divide it up by different political
committees which we can do or cannot do
I mean we can decide
I think for the ones that are quote
super Pacs we can't limit their
expenditures
under
um
federal law we can't limit those
expenditures
so
um but you can limit the the campaign
but the concern I always have
is
balancing
uh
the usefulness of transparency and
campaign
Finance for the public the voters
uh balance that against
the absolute respect I think we need to
have first the rights guaranteed by the
First Amendment right
and to me an exploratory committee
so-called I mean what
was to stop someone from collecting
money from people who like them to put
ads saying he's a terrific fella or a
wonderful woman or
an excellent individual
the person has a right to do that right
and so that's where
but that's why I can that's where I
could agree with the exploratory
committee designation just going away I
mean
someone could be exploring how much
support they might get they could
they could sponsor it people could
sponsor ads saying how wonderful they
are and then do polling there's nothing
to prevent that it shouldn't be anything
to prevent that all on their own
privately
that's an exploration
right
in a sense yep
I'm sorry I know I'm jumping in and out
of Representative there is fine
um
yes I know that's why so I'm that's why
I'm going to opine on it we welcome
whatever little bit of your time you can
spare us it seems to be it seems to be
fleeting
um
you know if we can't get rid of
exploratory altogether a easy compromise
would be to cap how much it can take in
entirely
say if you're going to form an
exploratory committee you may take in no
more than fifteen thousand dollars
period or something like that that's a
compromise if you didn't if I mean if we
all just want to get rid of it I I'm
fine with that it's I think it's just a
loop I don't say a loophole but I just
find the notion that you can raise
a bajillion dollars as an exploratory
committee it's like you're not exp if
you're if I raise a million dollars
around for state representative am I
exploring state representative
I think I I think I figured it out
representative
I mean the just the sort of mechanical
facts are that the cycle is you've
defined it accurately runs from the day
after an election a general election to
the day of the next general election so
that's the period of time in which
somebody might you know campaign more or
less officially and the only moment at
which we formally know somebody's a
candidate is the moment which they file
right and so that would just be roughly
the last six months of that 24-month
period which leaves open an 18-month
period in which they might raise and
spend money right but of course there's
no way to know they're a candidate
because they don't have to file until
June or whatever once they officially
file there are these two you know chunks
of the campaign the primary campaign and
then the general election campaign and
and so that's what creates this three
category categories but I think the
and and of course as you say there's
there's on one hand a kind of Freedom
value that says anybody should be able
to
you know raise and spend money to do
whatever is legal
um including Advanced their reputation
if that's the way that's a good way to
put it right that's what I had in mind
and there's also a
um you know kind of a corruption
anti-corruption
um that would normally be dispositive
and it would rule out any regulations on
what people can raise and spend at any
point in a campaign except that
you know citizens representatives and
courts have said that the public hasn't
you know an interest in
um monitoring what people raise and
spend and advancing themselves for
public office in an effort to combat
corruption and and so that is what
allows us to regulate what people raise
and spend but it's just that the
formalities of things allow us to do it
more effectively after they file and
less effectively in that window of time
before they file
and and so I see that you know the very
kind of
um
Instinct here is to is to treat this
whole window of time
um the same way and and say in that
whole window of time people should be
able to raise X
for advancing themselves and they have
to mean they have to let you know once
they hit a threshold let the voters know
who they're raising money from and what
they're spending money on
um yeah and we're not saying they can't
raise the money it's just basically you
just have to tell people how you're
spending the money who you're raising it
from and how you're spending it
so and and these are usually going to be
for the bigger races
so governor
executive Council and state senate
so
they would probably have staff doing
that
I like the phrase representative
Muirhead though about people raising
money and spending it to enhance their
reputation or or for that matter
publicize their views on various issues
of the day
because it does the uh our election
system have a legitimate interest you
know a compelling interest in regulating
that because people are free
to express their views on public on any
issue
and
so we have a con
telling transparency interest to
regulate or monitor that I'm not
convinced of that
in fact I'm I'm
from our past discussion should probably
understand already I'm biased against
regulation of free speech to begin with
and I really need a really good reason
to infringe on it
in my in my view so how do you separate
them
someone
just rephrase the question a little bit
if someone spends a year
uh publicizing their views on important
and sometimes controversial issues
and saying what how wonderful they'll be
for dealing with it but never ever
if we're going to put this in statute it
has to be defined so it's you know some
unambiguous set of criteria if we can do
that I mean
and and so also the people won't
be using the term loophole personally
I'm I'm actually kind of
fatigued with the word loophole because
to me if you're within the law are you
within the law as far as
the law is concerned
but anyway so there's my question
I think to that end you know my issue
with the quote exploratory phase is we
they start candidates start getting into
the level of ridiculousness of
if I were to run for governor or you
know
um and I think
maybe a summation we can all agree with
is
when is exploring no longer exploring
right and federally it's defined as when
they say I'm running for X right and
Statewide state in the state we say it's
when you file in June
um
so I think that's kind of
I guess that's something that I'm trying
to avoid in this is the Ridiculousness
of
if I was to run for a governor you know
um when they're not actually exploring a
race they're fully invested they have
staff right
um
you know and so I I get that I mean you
know an easy solution is to eliminate
the exploratory phase and just take the
15 grand and divide it up 75 and 75
um and call it a day
um I I think the filing period I know
that we taught that we tie the filing
period to campaign Finance laws
um
we don't have to do that the feds don't
do that they don't they don't tie filing
to that they do some on reporting they
they'll tie to report on reporting but
the feds you're a declared candidate
when you're declared when you declare
that you're a candidate doesn't mean we
have to do it that way I certainly have
my issue with how the feds handle things
um
but I I guess like that's kind of like
my sentiment is
I I just don't want candidates running
around being ridiculous saying you know
if I were if I were to run for governor
like nah bro you're you've raised two
million dollars you're running for
governor
um you know so I guess that that's kind
of my my sentiment on it is it the worst
of all evils no
um if we can clean it up get rid of it
or whatever
um if your issue is the limiting of the
speech
um
you know then you just they just
eliminate the period and break up the
15K over the two periods and
you effectively have the same
the same outcome without having the
Ridiculousness of if I were to run for
governor but one of my concerns also oh
sorry one of my concerns also was that
whatever we come up with we try to come
up with some
unambiguous Criterion
who's a candidate
with the hope that that will reduce the
amount of argument that has to take
place in the courts
now that's that's an idealistic notion
but because people are really you know
people are really clever
and people as a class are very good at
communicating in a way that you can't
that we can't really control nor should
we go ahead I'm sorry representative
you know I'll lay around all of the
exploratory activity Counterpoint as we
eliminate exploratory
away around it is they just form a pack
and they operate out of the pack until
they file
um and you see you see that happen all
the time
you know so it's like there's no perfect
outcome I just
I want to eliminate the Ridiculousness
you know perfect Perfection is not only
unobtainable it's really we really don't
even know what it would mean so
representative Muirhead
yeah and I think we can respect the
quality principle that
um that that aiming for Perfection you
know is a Fool's errand without at the
same time aim for some improvement over
the laws that are already on the books
with respect to the study right the
second thing we want to respect is your
you know what you're voicing the freedom
interest
in speech in general and in various
types of political speech and so the
only speech that we are addressing and
that our law is already address is
speech that aims to influence an
election right by promoting opposing
attacking
or supporting
um a measure or a candidate and and so
there's various political speech that
this doesn't include such as say if you
want to create a documentary in global
warming like Al Gore did and spent
millions and millions of dollars making
it that's not regulated by this if you
want to say you know if you have an
insurance company and you're going to
say
um you know Betsy Smith's uh jolly good
person and you should buy insurance from
her
um or a car dealership or whatever you
can promote your reputation with
Billboards and ads and radio spots also
with wouldn't be regulated by this code
um that kind of commercial speech so
this is only about influencing money
spent to influence an election
by supporting or opposing roughly
speaking measures or persons and
um and the question you know what you
want to do Ross as I understand it is
um
is
address in a in a consistent way this
period of time between the day after a
general election and the and when a
candidate files and and maybe you know
it'll turn out that the quality
principle of pursuing Perfection means
anything we try here just won't work and
we'll have to give it up but we should
at least see what we can do before
assuming we can't get any Improvement in
that
I'm sure having uh
look through the the election law our
election system laws the campaign
Finance laws and having looked at the
Secretary of State's Memo from Mr Fitch
I'm convinced I think we're all
convinced we can find areas of agreement
where things can be improved
even if just to remove contradictions
and
sources of confusion
I did have a thought about
you know sources of confusion about when
does this end right when we talked about
that with the loans two uh three weeks
ago yeah I did have some expounding
thoughts on that
um which is we could set the end of the
period as the certification of the
election
um because that is in fact the end when
the election is certified and all the
legal contests are over it's over at
that point it is done
um so that's a I just want to toss that
out there because I did have that
thought that may be a um
a happy middle ground for me wanting to
end it the day after the election and
other people wanted to go on for six
months
maybe the certification
um and see session secession
excuse me when it stops secession when
it stops no when all legal contests have
no and it sometimes that could be a
really long time though I mean as we've
if somebody really wants because there
was one that was being contested
to the ballot law commission quite a
long time
which one
I can't remember it was was it a senate
it was a senate maybe he wasn't
contesting it he wasn't contesting it I
I don't know oh I think I know what
you're talking about it was a senate it
was absentee Outlets
yes yes yeah I mean that the election
was certified it was over a member was
sat I mean it was done it was it like
what was
yeah what was to be gained right and we
did talk about the loan piece too as
well because you had mentioned if you
make a loan and you want to pay it back
um that would be you could you could
raise money to do that as long as you're
paying things off from your prior that
were occurred during your election if
you're raising new money to pay off
dance in other words there are no loans
that's going to be in the next election
cycle yes that we just figured we needed
a bright line so whether it's the date
of certification or whether it's the
date after I think it was just trying to
find a bright line
as to when those would be because you
know a lot of people do homes even you
know bank loans or whatever as long as
you're paying them off oh man let's take
a bank one run a campaign
yeah so you deserve to serve all the
well that's tied to my thought that we
should Define an election an election
cycle
by certain dates that everybody will
know
and you brought up the thought about uh
so that then we can define a previous
election cycle and a current election
cycle
and I think we need to make sure that
candidates still have the opportunity to
raise funds if people will contribute to
pay off loans they they took for the
previous election cycle
currently you can retain those funds you
can only spend them for
uh
if you run in one the preview if you ran
in the previous election cycle you can
retain those funds under your control
but they can only be used
for certain specific politically related
purposes or uh to be donated to an
approved charity am I getting that right
and you can roll them over to the next
Camp the the current
election cycle do they leave anything
out there Ross no I mean it's I I that's
the basics I've said before I have I
have issues with that because that's not
how the money is going to work but what
would happen is they would if I took out
a twenty thousand dollar loan and my
election ended and I won
and I had twenty thousand dollars
sitting on the book and then Russ wanted
to give me 20 grand to help me pay off
my loans I would then on paper pay off
my loans and then give myself another
twenty thousand dollar loan on the other
side because the money has already been
spent
um and that that's my problem is it's
that that rolling of the loan is is
what's going to happen is they're just
gonna it's it's a way for Russ to give
me forty thousand dollars
um
which I look forward to that check
um I thought I already gave you that oh
well it didn't clear so you should have
got a note well if if the loan appear
like I guess it
so is he going to be able to give then
over the campaign contribution amount
right is that what you're saying that's
my concern yes if they'll be able to
to the extent that campaign Finance laws
should exist within the confines of the
First Amendment they should be
equally applied rigid and right not once
again
not easily circumventable that doesn't
mean that we will be able to prevent
everything I'm not I thought we're not
going to get Perfection yeah I'm not so
um
I'm not so naive to believe that we
could do that but I do believe that you
can knock out the main easy ways that
are that are done to right
um I don't want to use the term loophole
because that's not appropriate but to
so what the the scenario as I understand
it that you're suggesting is something
where I have
a
um you know campaign of your head in
2014 year in 2016 year in 2018 2020 2022
they they all are in debt because of the
money I spent I essentially loaned the
campaigns and I can raise money to to
pay off those debt to myself
um simultaneously for all those
campaigns and each campaign has its own
limit then I could raise a lot of money
yeah I mean you could do something as as
create you know you pay off twenty
thousand dollars and then remember
you're allowed to give to your campaign
an unlimited amount of money it's your
campaign so then you paid off twenty
thousand dollars in debt from 2020 and
now you've made a twenty thousand dollar
contribution from yourself into 2022
you know once again
um circumventing the intention of the
election Finance contribution loss
that's that's my issues with I I have I
have huge issues with loans just because
of how
it's an accounting trick to move money
around that that's what it is what's the
reality is is the people who loan money
into campaigns the reality is people who
loan money into campaigns know they're
not getting it back
that's the reality you can make the
statement if it's a loan they expect to
get it back the reality is they know
they're not getting it back
um
now he tells us so so what happens then
yeah don't you wish you'd known that
uh if you don't give it back then you
just have it you maintain it on your
books and you carry a deficit for that
election you have to keep filing a
report forever I mean every six months
right I I would make you could the way
you close it up is you'd say if you
insert date that we could quibble over
um you're eating you know the loan the
loan shall not be paid back and you're
you know the the candidates eating that
it's close it's done okay
you've you have you have you know if
you've won your election you have six
months or however long it is right now
it's six months to go and backfill that
like give it six months to backfill that
so the loan then if it's a self-made
loan so if it's a loan from the
candidate oh yeah I've never seen a loan
that wasn't from the candidate okay I
just checking okay so you have to be
from the candidate because if it's from
another entity that entity is now making
a campaign Finance violation exactly so
I guess you could have I guess that's
where I was headed yeah yeah I I guess
in theory you could I guess in theory
anyone could loan a campaign up to the
Limit
um
in theory
so you're talking specifically loans
made by a candidate to his or her own
campaign once virtually all campaign
finances I understand you're saying
that's virtually all but you are taught
you are talking specifically about loans
a candidate makes
to that candidate's own campaign right I
have never seen a loan in campaign
Finance from anyone other than right but
you're not answering my question I'm not
sorry I'm not trying to dodge it what is
the question specifically but I
understand that you're saying it's a
practical I'm sorry I didn't mean to
sound that way no it's okay but you're
saying as a practical matter you've
never seen a case of a loan to a
campaign except from the candidate
correct the candidates themselves and I
would imagine that if another entity
made a loan
to a candidate it would have to be by
definition a contribution right
um and at that point I would question if
it's a loan because if it's a
contribution in and you pay it back well
that's just refunding a contribution
so so I had one more thought so
again you're talking
simply
specifically about loans that candidates
make to their own campaigns yes and what
I'm getting what I'm getting from your
comments is that that would be it would
be adequate
to Define it that way in a statute
because you've never as a practical
matter you've never seen another any
other kind of loan yes I I yes that is
correct I I would love to find the bank
that would loan me a million dollars and
run for governor
and then you'd move to the Caribbean or
no I would just close up the committee
and they'd go after the dead entity
that's why they would never do it anyway
like loaning money to an LLC
you don't have any assets they're not
I don't
I don't see a problem on the face of it
with
putting a limit on how long a candidate
has to clear a loan that that candidate
made
the candidates make for their own
you don't always understand everything
about an idea in the first few minutes
right but on the face of it I don't see
a
yeah that don't react as that being an
issue that's my I don't want the loan
used as an accounting trick to
run around the the laws that we've spent
a long time we are spending a long time
trying to
to set that being said if a candidate
wants to loan their campaign a hundred
thousand dollars that's their business
they have a right to put in as much as
they want
um and if donors want to give to them
under the
awesomenesses that they could be
repaying back the loan from the
candidate that's fine I just have a
problem when that's being done six years
down the road right so what you're
saying is you're proposing there'd be a
time limit
during which for that election cycle but
that loan from the candidate could be
paid back
correct uh okay let's think about that
that's that's what I'm talking about
yeah representative mirrorhead you had a
comment
so I think we should get the right
advice we need to deal with the loan
issue um plausible to me that various
entities might make effective loans to a
campaign if I go and I buy a hundred
pizzas for your campaign
and I've already hit the contribution
limit then your campaign needs to refund
me for those hundred pizzas I've
effectively made a loan of the value of
those pizzas or if you rent a fleet of
Vans for get out of the boat no you've
made it if you go and buy 100 pizzas
you've made an in-kind contribution you
have bought an item you have you have
bought an item and then immediately made
an expenditure with it
um so you're on both sides of electric
so if you bought 100 pizzas a thousand
bucks you know you you would have an
in-kind contribution rust from your head
a thousand dollars on the uh receipt
Into The Ledger and you'd have a
thousand dollars uh income contribution
on the expenditure lips they're perhaps
on the same day and that's current law
and it counts towards your threshold
what if I've already hit the threshold
and I buy some pizzas just to facilitate
the the event and I expect the campaign
to pay me back for those pizzas because
I've already hit the limit then in
theory you have made a um so if the
campaign pays you back that's not really
a loan you that's just them reimbursing
you for an expenditure there's a period
of time between the time I pay for those
pizzas and the time in which they pay me
back and during that time I've made them
alone I think it would be the
expectation
right if I go and I buy pizzas for
volunteers at noon and I give it to them
at one o'clock and then at five o'clock
you've reimbursed me I mean because in
that sense any staffer who files an
expenditure report at the end of the
month has made an in-kind contribution
but there's no expect there's the
expectation that they'd be paid back
immediately versus a candidate loan is
there's no expectation to be paid back
immediately
or within 30 days or whatever you know I
I don't I I totally see where you're
saying it's actually kind of a brilliant
way to get there but um I don't think
that that would be
I don't think that would qualify as a
loan that's
that's a you know it's almost like a
vendor yeah it's like yeah like a vendor
like if you know and there's yeah that's
a great way to put it like you know I
don't know which there are some vendors
that have terms
with
um parties and candidates of you know
net 30 day and that sort of stuff that's
not an in-kind contribution or legal
fees right
um if if you you know you don't even
know what the bill is you're incurring
the services but there's the expectation
that you'll be paid back
um
an in-kind contribution would be you buy
the pizzas with the expectation you
don't get paid back this is a good
example though what we all all
understand which I was saying earlier
people are very clever about finding
ways to do things so we we can't control
it all can we make some changes that
improve things and all this business
with loans and repaying and all that the
candidate under the current system that
is still transparent people can find out
that's going on
yeah and when you see you know on
reimbursements to what representative
muirhead's trying to sit but saying is
they don't go in if you let's take the
the pizzas again right and you expect to
be reimbursed for the pizzas you're not
buying them for the campaign volunteers
you are buying them with the expectation
of being reimbursed it wouldn't go in as
one thousand dollars of pizzas to
representative Muirhead it would go in
as one thousand dollars of pizzas to pop
from Papa John uh two pot an expenditure
to Papa John's your name actually in
theory should never appear on it because
you didn't make the pizzas all you did
was buy them and transport them
um that's how that's how that's supposed
to be done otherwise you can ossificate
literally anything
um in an exponential line by saying it's
a reimbursement clouded through a vendor
representative Riverhead you had a
comment and on the
just the earlier your earlier concern
Ross about the exploratory period
um
you know one one
possible solution would be to have a law
that says something like right any
person or group that raises or spends X
dollars whatever the threshold is to
peso a measure person
um
during an election cycle must you know
register as a candidate or committee and
must not raise more than why dollars
whatever the limit is from any person or
group
and and at that point we get away with
the distinction between exploratory
Primary in general
um
and uh and treat treat both you know
persons and groups the same is that is
that the kind of thing you're you want
to work toward yes simplification less
entity types streamline uniform
contribution limits
um I would love it if RSA 664 was like
four pages
not with loopholes or no I know it's not
the word use um not with um easy ways to
circumvent the intent of the legislator
unnecessarily complex aspects of it and
specifically with exploratory committees
what I've used the Ridiculousness of it
um there's a person running for governor
right now who is marching in parades
raising funds and says they are
exploring a race for governor they have
staff
they are running a campaign there is
nothing exploring about that they are
doing that and not going to name names
because it's not no point to it I'm just
saying it happens it happens every day I
wasn't doing that right uh there's one
that I'm aware of
um but I I am sure I am to your point
I'm sure there will be more
um and it's not to say that that
candidate exploratory candidate is doing
anything wrong or nefarious it's just
ridiculous just declare what you're
running for
um because your exploratory phase ended
when you raised a hundred thousand
dollars or whatever it was
um you know you have the funds you need
to figure out if you want to run or not
because nothing stops you from stopping
and running at any point including if
you file for a primary Nothing Stops you
just your name just doesn't come off the
ballot
because I I've always viewed the filing
period as
these are the names that go on the
ballot
and a little more than that because the
reality is is the primary
the primary not to get in the primary
date discussions but the primary doesn't
begin the first week of June we all know
that that's
a joke like we all know that's that
that's not true the primary begins when
candidates start running for that office
the year before that a year before that
which by the way is totally their right
probably the smart thing to do
politically
um but let's not act like it's anything
my issue with exploratory candidacy is
it acts like it's something that it's
not
and like let's just drop the pretense of
what it is you know there's very little
in politics there's very little
legitimate
exploratory activity there is some
there is some I would never say that
there's none
but the reality is is once you start
getting to certain thresholds
you know if you raise a million dollars
in an exploratory campaign you're going
to tell me that that person's not
running
like come on now like a million dollars
to advance their name and their ideas
um
you know and they don't even need by the
way they don't even need to declare an
office like you can form a candidate's
com or I know we don't call it anymore
but we can form a candidate a
candidate's committee or whatever the
term you want to use right
does the contribution limits are the
same across the board for State offices
so it doesn't it doesn't matter you're a
candidate for office period it doesn't
matter the the limits the contribution
limit for State Rep are the same as the
contribution limits for governor council
state senate
um they're all exactly the same so it's
it's even if you changed your mind it
so what exactly are you proposing we
change
what I would propose
um is eliminate the exploratory phase in
the interests of what I would believe
your concerns and also my concerns is
that we don't artificially depress the
contribution limit so take the five five
and five and make it 75 and 75
call it a day I could personally
tolerate a world where it was five and
five but if we need a compromise to get
to the two phases that's fine and if you
want to leave exploratory phase in there
for legitimate exploratory phase
activity put in a low a total receipt
limit not individual donor receipt limit
total organizational receipt limit
we can debate over that number what it
may be
um
but that would be
um but that would be if I was making
let's call it the ideal system
um representative Ward you know that
that's what I would go because I you
know is it semi going to form an
exploratory committee for that's to go
to the chair you guys are subtle
Persian class
um
you know is anybody here going to form
an exploratory committee to run for
state representative or are you just
so legitimate question like but for
governor by the way I think there is a
legitimate phase of that um you gotta
ask your spouse and if your spouse won't
support you
you've had it that's the explanation if
that was the case I wouldn't have won
twice
I believe my wife did tell me she voted
to get she told me she voted against me
the first time and voted for me the
second time you know she said I earned
that vote the second time
um
it was because she liked how how much I
was out of the house she was like oh
I do too
I kind of like the idea of just having
one
kind of
this is the time
and to just blend them all together yeah
in terms of contribution limits that's
kind of what we're that's what we're
talking about here basically because do
we really need two phases even Primary
in general do we need those
again I'm not suggesting we change
anything about how these amounts are
reported
I mean I looked at that again last night
and
uh you know the reporting element would
stay the same but do we need to have
separate limits for a primary and a
general election
individual you know those are individual
con those are contributions from
individuals basically
yeah I mean organization that's I mean
part of me is like no because I mean I
know that some people might want to wait
to see who wins the primary and then
give that money but they can still do
that in other words they give the person
save the total amount is 15 they give
them 10 and then if they win the primary
they give them another five there are
there are a lot of
donors that do that
um right and they still could they still
could it doesn't change their behavior
so I'm just wondering what is that
division doing well I don't know so the
to answer the question what it does is
it prevents
what that does is it prevents the money
from being spent in the primary so if
the contribution limits are five five
and five right now let's just say five
and five for keep it simple for right
now if if I go and I give you ten
thousand dollars in theory you can only
spend five thousand of that dollars
and if you don't make it through the
primary you have to give me my money
back
um
or you have to spend it I guess on your
I don't know exactly how the state laws
are written but I think you'd have to
like you'd have you can't spend that
five Rand that second five grand until
you until after the primary phase is
over
um and there are like on the federal
side I know you cannot spend that money
um and that if you don't win your
primary you actually do have to give it
back
I don't know that we have that in state
I don't know if you have to give it back
in state um my my understanding is
I'd have to look it up to quote it
exactly I don't want to take the time
right slow the conversation down but my
understanding from having read that
recently
if you have money left over at the end
of a campaign
whether primary or general when the
campaign's over
you can use it for certain
politically related purposes you can
donate to another candidate I believe
you know in the next election cycle
uh you can roll it over and if you're
going to run again for some office you
can use it for that purpose or you can
donate it to
a charitable
uh organization of some type and I think
that's you know specified some approved
charitable organization that's how I
understand you have to use the funds if
you're not using them in another
campaign serps unless there's other
political purpose or charitable purpose
you can't the main point is you cannot
convert it to personal use
which we all have to agree that that
makes perfect sense to me okay
someone wants to look it up no I'm
looking here at a surplus campaign
contributions Surplus campaign
contributions may be used after a
general or special election for
fundraising activities and any
politically related activity sponsored
by the candidate or for donations to
charitable organizations such Surplus
contributions however shall not be used
for personal purposes I believe
representative you nailed that okay
impressive
does it again it does it again
you sound surprised no I'm routinely
it's the first 10 minutes of the
basketball game last night
please let's not go there
uh so
So reading this could you you couldn't
give it to your party
related activity sponsored by the
candidate
so what does that mean well I don't it's
ambiguous so Surplus campaign
contributions may be used for general or
spectral election maybe just after a
general or special election fund for
fundraising activities
fundraising activity
I work less about Surplus yeah it was
thank you um what to do about surplus
funds got it because it came up in my
confusion of filing my own personal
campaign
what do I do with it
um
so we all love it when election laws go
to the courts
no
you know if there's really no way to
write a campaign Finance law that
doesn't get no I I remember uh one of
the first things that chairman Griffin
told me
said
Ross there's you should know you should
be aware there's three election law
committees there's the house the Senate
yeah I don't see it but I'm pretty sure
he talked about it about Surplus I was
just looking in his memo
oh from the Secretary of State I'm sure
they mentioned that what to do with
Surplus was a question that they get and
we can go back and ask but I I think we
still I still think we need to clarify
664 colon colon 4 dash B right
Surplus campaign contributions on page
so and then another question I had when
we were talking about loans and going
back and forth There's No Limit right
now and I'm not advocating we have one
on an individual the amount of
self-funding by an individual it's not
clear to me
how many people
report that
and if it's reportable and I guess my
thought would be from a transparency
standpoint not saying you can't find but
if you're going to sell fund that you
disclose that
I think you do have to disclose that
already it's on the Forum contributions
by candidate
you'd have to put it in yeah yeah you
can't just that was my impression too my
first campaign a couple years ago I made
myself you know a small loan just to get
the bank account up and running but I
had a separate bank account right
and then I did repay that you know after
the election but I reported all that
so that was my understanding
I don't bother with the loan I don't
think the money's coming back excuse me
set it in there I said I don't bother
with the loan because I don't think the
money's coming back
if I'm honest even with myself I I
always I always put in my own campaign
it makes it easier to have other people
give me money as a Tom look I'm invested
because you you're gonna get that 100 a
year job well I
it's my opinion
I'm not limiting the discussion and
that's not my job as a chairman of this
particular subcommittee but
we I think we've discussed
the phases of the election cycle and
exploratory committees it seems like we
have a general sentiment here amongst us
that we could dispense with exploratory
committee as a category of political
Primary in general
yeah in terms of contribution limits in
terms of campaign Finance contribution
limits yes one one we'll have to debate
what the total because at that point if
we go to singular status
we would have to have a debate on to
what the
contribution limit would be from an
individual donor for singular status I I
think
so so right now there's three phases at
five grand each right right if you get
rid of the phases
um
you are you know we can't just go from
fifteen thousand dollar contribution
limit to five thousand dollars yeah
right I would just make it 15. and then
30 for I mean you just want the total Rd
is I'll be optimistic and think that
keeping the total aggregate amount the
that's way too optimistic I know right
but I think it makes sense that it if
on one phase that we had over three
phases then
there's no
no effective difference no practical
change
there is some practical change
um it does accomplish a political goal
of mine which is to end the incumbent
protection plan that is our campaign
Finance laws
um and say that again emotionally it
helps end the incumbent protection plan
that is our campaign Finance laws how so
because by removing the three phases
right income non-incumbents tend to get
into the race later right incumbents who
are running again just re-up their
campaign immediately right oh yeah okay
so by eliminating that by getting rid of
the potential by the three phases you
allow
non-incumbence basically access to the
same not basically the access to the
same level of resources that an
incumbent has
even though they get into the Ritz later
um
and you know how I feel about the
incumbent protection plans
uh which is hilarious given that I'm an
incumbent
all the time like why can't you fix this
like it's hard to get incumbents to get
rid of the income protection plan it's
you really have to you really have to
put your own selfishness so I was being
overly optimistic when I said it might
not be controversial okay well I
actually I think it fairness standpoint
I think if that's what if you're driven
by Notions of
fairness and and reducing barriers to
participation it but not everyone's
driven by that
yeah that's that's when it comes to this
sort of stuff I like and I'm an
egalitarian I like it to be
okay I think that Prince Will Be by many
sympathizers I could I I would feel
comfortable defending that principle or
promoting it we're going to treat
and then you don't have to worry about
the you know if I were to run
I'm running for governor not me the
state's not ready for that yeah thank
all right well
okay so are we kind of I mean
we are going to I think representative
Whaley have a list
yeah I have a short list here of things
that seem to me uh
uh I kind of uh
okay I'm still getting this my thinking
organized on this but yeah Clarity
Clarity revisions
I had
two sub bullets and a sub bullet for one
of them uh first one refine and improve
the definitions we've identified some
definitions in our our first meeting I
think that
and you've come up with a a beginning
list which I haven't had time to read
yet but I will
uh
and then I have another category called
removing
internal contradictions that's just a
working
label
uh candidate versus candidate committee
I think a common set of reporting
deadlines for candidates and candidate
committees would it's kind of a low
hanging fruit when you look at what the
actual deadlines are for a political
committee you know a candidate committee
to report
I mean it's it's very close to the six
month
continuing requirement for a candidate
remember the table in uh make it all the
same it should be like that's right
super low hanging fruit nobody should
have an objection to that
right basically I'd say you know the
make candidates
committees subject to the same six-month
continuing reporting requirement until
the balance
on the uh
uh
and another one that should be is it was
some some seeming discrepancies
about
the reporting period that you you have
to report on yeah it was uh some places
it's what was it was uh you have to
report for the period up and up till
Sunday and
you know some ambiguity as to what the
actual end date of the period you're
reporting on the following Wednesday
and so just make that period make Sunday
the last day for each campaign Finance
system reporting period make it explicit
you know your reporting activity
through Sunday you know inclusive
maybe just put that word in
so you get you get a donation
or make an expense on Monday it doesn't
go on that report that's due on the
Wednesday
so you're looking like I'm not making
sense no that's just the current law
because you want to make it clear I want
to make it clear right I'm not changing
what I think the intent is but make one
of the things they told us in that
discussion we had with the Secretary of
State's office Secretary of State
Scanlon and Mr Fitch
was that they get a lot of questions
about that
because in one place I don't it's in the
list he gave us and one place it says
uh
I don't remember the exact wording maybe
someone else can find it but uh it was
some it's not in the law it was in his
list
uh
anyway just make it clear that your
reporting activity through the midnight
on the Sunday before the Wednesday
you're filing the report that should be
easy
seven
no three on page seven I'm clearly a
good morning
such statements are filed and itemized
all receipts and expenditures since the
cutoff the statement under paragraph two
up until the Monday preceding the filing
and
Roman numeral 2-a and then 664 6 looks
like Roman numeral one
requires report up to including the
Monday before the statement is due I
don't care if it's Sunday or Monday
but just make it the same wording in
both those
uh portions of the statute
right
no argument about that right right
that's an easy one
and uh and we already touched on this
earlier you know we've got Financial
agent Fiscal Agent and treasurer pick
one I personally would say Financial
agent but whatever pick one
there's easy things I mean
and they are you know details but with
details that are causing people
confusion
and increasing the workload of the
Secretary of State's office also
unnecessarily
uh well we talk some
uh it's my thought
about
mandatory use of the online campaign
Finance system now my view of it is
generally speaking that I think it's a
good idea again for so so the
information is more accessible to the
can be made more accessible to the
public
but we also I think have to make
provision for people who
have uh difficulties with computer
skills or availability or
online access is
there are a lot of parts of the state I
think there are still many parts of the
state which do not have good internet
access
that's been worked on but anyway I think
we have to make accommodations for
people who are in that kind of situation
because again we don't want to create
barriers to participation so Mr
representative for us so yes
um and I think the way we do that is we
look at the financial
the threshold for filing
so if somebody takes in
thousand dollars they spent a thousand
dollars on their campaign for or
received uh receipts see yeah I thought
because you know I'm a big fan of or
right it's one or the other
um
if they reach that threshold then they
have to use the system
and my argument I was throwing a
thousand dollars out now we can we can
have that conversation with what it
should be but if you've taken in a
thousand dollars of political money I
would argue that you have the
currently they don't have to you're not
required to file a report isn't it a
thousand dollars now was it raised it
was raised to a thousand expenditures or
receipts yes and if you don't have that
level of activity you don't even have to
file a report correct to begin with yes
and I make yeah and I would make the
other argument is under that amount
active their activity is largely not
meaningful
if the goal of the trans if the goal of
that the the purpose of the limit right
is so that the public has a vested
interest in knowing what's happening
right if you know I don't think
anybody's getting bought off for a
thousand dollars for a hundred dollar a
year job right it's a bigger shame on
you sure
foreign
was a very powerful powerful powerful
tool right um but no it's whatever the
limit is I mean I I think if you don't
qualify for the limit and the limit's a
thousand dollars
you know you probably if you if you've
taken in a thousand dollars of
expenditures you've probably in ever
seats you've probably had the
sophistication to use the internet
um
and the money to buy a computer
if you don't have one or at least a
small one that you can tablet
a tablet okay
yeah we can discuss whether the the
thousand dollar amount is
quite high enough but yeah okay I'm
seeing your point yeah
I mean you could make that argument you
could just say you know if you've
whatever if it's over two thousand
dollars then you have to use the online
system
the point the point the justification
for the campaign Finance system being
that the public will be aware if there's
a possibility of undue influence
yeah and what I've suggested before for
the
um
mandatory use of the online system is
phasing in over the years
um State reps being last not because I
preference ourself just because we're
the smallest races taking the least
amount of money
um but if I was if I was to set it
unilaterally it would be governor and
all packs
um one cycle then the next cycle I would
do Council and state senate and then
finally six years out I would do state
reps
just a phase in over time
um I was more aggressive if you want to
go more aggressive I'm happy to talk
about being more aggressive but that's
that would at least start walking Us in
the right direction if if we as a
practical matter if we form a consensus
among this subcommittee and then the
full committee election law committee
agrees with us
we still have roughly
300 and some 82 other people potentially
who also need to agree what I have found
is with dealing with our fellow members
is that when you put requirements on
them very far down the road they tend to
be a little more agreeable to them
because they think in their head oh that
won't apply to me
oh because they will be running correct
it's a body that has 33 of the body
turns over every year so in you know in
six years you've had the potential for
nearly 100 turnover right that's
obviously not 100 tomorrow but you've
had right a significant percentage of
turnover because that hundred dollars a
year only goes 87 30 after taxes by the
way
in State Senate and in the packs for the
first one and then
executive Council and the Reps so I
would Swip out Swip out switch out the
Senate and the council
because uh the Senate yeah send the
council because remember we have to get
the Senate to vote for this too right so
if we just it's a practical side the
other side of the body has to support
this so if if you just say hey I guess
what you're going to start using the
mandatory reporting they might go whoa
um if you give them two years to get
their ducks in a row
maybe that maybe their Senate Brands can
then handle it and and the members of
the other chamber are also I think you
know part-time volunteers really right
yeah they only get paid 100 a year too
no comments
so that would make
the first group in 2026
yeah the next group in 2028 and then the
house wraps
and I guess anybody else I can't
remember is anybody else that falls into
these into the County Commissioners
that's what I was wondering but anybody
else County maybe not you know what I
don't remember but sheriffs encounters
anybody else would come in in 2030. yeah
that's only six G's
um that we did hear a testimony from the
Secretary of State's office that they
did not want mandatory enrollment this
cycle just right heads up
um we don't have we don't have to agree
with that assessment from the Secretary
of State's office but well just to put
it out there I think the other handful
and redoing mention that and and Aaron's
I remember things see I remember things
when they said
not feeling
so just something to think we don't have
to follow that guidance um we are
definitely able to do what we want
um but just again you were thinking uh
Governor starting when
in the 2026 2020 yeah that's why I like
the governor
Pax starting first they're relatively I
mean the packs actually make up a large
links but
um
it keeps it keeps the legislative bodies
that would be averse to it away from it
and um
it uh that's where the bulk of the money
is getting spent anyways so that that
covers the larger swath of money which
in theories will be these a smaller
number of the file links
more money less filings and then we roll
into less money more filings and the uh
at the governor's
level and for PAX they are dealing with
enough money they can afford the staff
to make sure they can meet the
requirement
uh my experience with the and I know
we're getting a new cfis system my
experience is that the cfis system is
faster
oh yeah it's actually easier to use I've
been using it and it's it's for the most
part it's got yeah there's got some
quirks yeah but
um so where do you want to put executive
Council on the first group or the second
I put them in the first group okay the
first group I mean well the counselors
are raising some serious cash now I know
this is not and there's only five of
them there's only five of them I mean
there's there's counselors pulling in a
quarter of a million dollars
um that's not nothing
you know the Senators they kind of
outside of the leadership okay they tend
to cap out around a hundred
um obviously that goes up every single
year just by virtue of inflation and
that sort of stuff but it generally
speaking by doing Governor Council on
all tax you covered the lar once again
the biggest pool of money
um
I mean in an Ideal World we would want
to I would say put House and Senate
together
in the same year that's four years from
now to figure it out but once again we
have to pitch that to our colleagues and
sometimes they can
just from a system trying
part of me is wondering you know if you
bring on Four Is there big that big a
difference of bringing in 400 or 424
although it's more than that because
it's everybody else running so it's
going to be yeah 800 and just the
general yeah but the but but that's
assuming they get over a thousand
dollars and yeah okay all right how many
state reps are raising more than a
thousand dollars not a lot of us well
there are significant number who don't
yeah oh yeah I probably I would just say
more don't than do you know most of
these guys and gals are just buying
their yard signs and a couple of palm
cards and moving on yeah
the larger the districts the more
competitive I mean it's like all things
in politics right the larger the
district the more competitive the
district the more the campaign cash is
flowing well the larger the district the
more people you have to reach that's yep
that's that's uh you're not going to
reach I represent half a Senate District
how big is your District 30 000
constituents and you're not gonna you're
not going to reach 30 000 doing door
knocking I've attempted yeah yeah I have
attempted uh I I door knocked the first
time I ran in the flow I door knocked
myself 4 500 doors
um
it's a lot of but it's to be fair I have
Manchester so it's not like you know
it's not far to walk in between the
houses
very few Russ very very few well they
did they didn't know him then
yeah sorry
oh fun fact second time out I got more
votes they loved it yeah old joke I
couldn't resist sorry he's our guy he's
our guy
yes
okay what else you were doing candidate
versus candidate committee and then we
got
those 300 internal contradictions uh
okay make the same reporting deadlines
for candidates and candidate committees
make Sunday or
make the last day to report for the
succeeding the last day of activity to
be reported for a given report make it
the same I think Sunday makes sense it's
you know Monday
I guess from what I remember from when I
was a kid Sunday is officially the first
day of the week but in terms of economic
activity it still is kind of Monday
right so I would go with I would go with
through Sunday
uh
and yeah Financial agent or
or just one term I like treasure that's
what it's worth
I don't have a I don't have a preference
on which of those three examples that
are currently in the statute we use
the United States Department of the
treasury not the United States
Department of fiscal agents
well everybody knows what a Treasurer is
pretty much I think it's a word in
common use the other thing that does
happen to that point is you'll see
they'll write on there I know we're
going to work on the disclaimer Alliance
they'll write on their FA and then
they'll list the Fiscal Agent as a wink
nod
it's hard to do I don't know what you
would do for treasurer p-r-e-a-s period
I think that's it but that that's
obvious right fa is not obvious
assuming we can't get my dream of not
having to list your Fiscal Agent and
your address on your disclaimers
we're getting there okay yeah actually
um
I'm not sure how to even enforce that
someone buys a bunch of signs they don't
put their name on it and they're
unconnected with a candidate and put
them out is can you practically track in
a practical matter can you track that
person down who put the signs out but
that's that's an issue for another day
uh
representative yeah I'm taking a look
well another committee another political
committee type
we discussed
a voluntary committee as for someone
that's where a group
is not obligated to register with the
Secretary of State's office
so why do we even offer the opportunity
and the counter argument to not doing it
was that well at some some committees
find that useful in terms of their
fundraising to have some official status
but is that really
do we need to add another type of
political committee to ease their
fundraising I mean they it's kind of up
to them to to gain the confidence of
potential contributors I think
so is that one we could dispense with
which one it's there's one called a
voluntary uh
oh yeah yeah they just decide they want
to they want to and what we heard in the
discussion right was that some
organizations
find this helpful in soliciting donation
you know contributions
but it yeah number seven on page four
okay thank you
um
right political committee voluntary
registration
any segregated fund not required or not
required to register and Report receipts
so can we is that one with that's
nine different this is on page one very
first line in this write-up actually
issues one nine different types of
registration is very complex
that
um no
no I don't see one but the types are
64 2 I think
right now yeah
well I just said the explanation we had
for why there's apparently some
sentiment in favor of it
I think representative qualey said the
reasons they want to look more official
for raising funds but I don't and I can
understand why that might be more
advantageous for some groups
without the explicit authorization you
can make the argument the Secretary of
State could reject the filing
so that could be another reason why it
was put in there
I don't think that they would but you
could see that argument
oh you haven't met the threshold you
don't need a file
exactly
the committee type is re this is the
last sentence in the description the
full description as a voluntary
registration there is no deadline for
registration however once registered
voluntary registration political
committee must comply with receipts and
expenditures for reporting requirements
the committee type is revised to the
applicable type
if the committee's receipts and or
expenditures reach the level that
I think I mean I'm not adamant on this I
mean it's just I'm not seeing the need
for it I I'm I'm fine deleting it I
don't see the point of it if our goal is
to streamline it what's the point I
guess can somebody make the argument
keeping it in
I I don't know we can go back and ask
the Secretary of State I mean if unless
there's an argument to keep it in this
is one of those without objections did
somebody making notes on these things
because
thank you the president alert is quickly
writing
I say that with all love
yeah another item I had in the list was
previous election cycle contributions
and
it had to do with uh
limiting them to
uh satisfying debt that had been
incurred and I think and your point on
that so I'll go over this one more time
to fix it in my mind
you're concern about that was
as a practical matter
you're you're not aware of anyone
besides a candidate that loans to a
campaign it just doesn't happen
very often if at all in my 12 years of
uh reading Finance campaign Finance
reports yep um which there may be one
other person in the state who's read
that as many as much as I have the other
person is probably in the room uh I am
not aware of a single instance in which
a loan has been given to a candidacy
that wasn't from the candidate were you
just a moment ago referring to someone
else as the resident nerd
yes did I hear that right oh okay just
curious
I love reading campaign Finance reports
I'm sick in the head like that
your way of addressing that concern
was to set a deadline by which a
candidate has to have those repay those
loans correct no other no contribute
basically whatever the deadline is no
contribution after that day can be put
towards repaying that loan the loan is
effectively at that point what the
remainder of that loan is converted to a
contribution from the candidate
which doesn't violate any limits because
there are no limits on candidate
contributions to their own campaigns
correct
I think that that sounds reasonable we
can discuss the details of how long they
would have but I I would make it a day
you know but I also wouldn't make it
unlimited like it is now or it could be
interpreted to be now
yeah
giving a state certain a a defined
period after the election that is
reasonable
maybe a year
again we we can find something that's
reasonable reasonable I can debate we
can we won't do it today but we can
debate what reasonable is we don't need
to figure that out today
all right I think that that approach
so far sounds
that was just on my list that we hadn't
you know that I had so far
and that's a transparency issue too so I
mean I feel like yeah I feel like all
science can walk away from that with the
Wind
[Music]
would the committee be interested in
soliciting comments from members of the
public who are present or sure or uh
baby representative from the Secretary
of State's office
fellow fellow campaign Finance nerds you
know this really gets people you know
people get really excited about campaign
Finance
it's really it's a it's a real
you know well I'm finding it interesting
third rail of New Hampshire politics
does that mean does that mean I'm uh
one of the resident marriage then
probably by virtue of sitting on this
committee we are all the residential
nerds when our own committee members are
like oh I don't know if I want to send a
campaign Financial like ah yeah
yeah
well that's consistent being a nerd on
this committee is
consistent with the rest of my life
history so
no complaints
I'm going to invite uh Secretary of
deputy secretary of state
Aaron
if you have some thoughts you'd like to
share with us having listened to our
discussion
we have uh 26 minutes before the meeting
ends
thanks for
your diligence continuing to look at
this uh secretary Scanlon did want me to
let you know that he is continuing to
work on possible suggestions to
um especially the definition section and
what a committee is and
what the options are
um and just listening to your past
discussion on debt I just want to remind
the committee that there is other forms
of debt other than loans sometimes bills
for your campaign don't come in right
away especially when you've hired staff
or
there'll be a time period where there'll
be other
debts that come in that are not self
loans to your committee
um but there but that there should be a
time period where that election cycle
ends and the next one begins
so when you're looking at dates for
campaign Finance reporting online
whatever that date is
for the 2026 cycle perhaps it's November
30th of 24 that that reporting online
has to start
um just thinking thinking of all
the information that you have to digest
and require for
those who are required to use the online
campaign Finance system so whatever you
set as the end date of an election cycle
all right
I'm happy to take some questions take
some questions back to the office I see
your point on that the November the 2026
elections right Naturals
a natural start of that election cycle
would be after the general election in
2024 which is what we were discussing
earlier that was my thinking
and I think to the our voluntary
comments sometimes somebody voluntarily
submits information it's not a committee
it's just that they think they're going
to spend more than a thousand dollars so
they voluntarily self-report before that
deadline is
or that threshold is met so
um that's what the voluntarily reporting
comment was made from our office at so
if you voluntarily report your expenses
expenses and contributions before the
thousand dollar limit
you have to continue to report those
even though you haven't met the thousand
for example someone who's a candidate
yes
any any across the board any anyone
but any of those committee types
political committee types could do yes
anyone could do that so we don't
okay so again I'm not seeing a need for
a special
oh no it's not a special type of
committee it's just right but we it's
the list requirements of reporting that
they're required to do and the list from
we we got from the Mr Fish prepared
which I'm going to say again has been
very very useful he listed that as one
of the nine types of political committee
that's defined
and we're it's looking to be even more
so since your comments that that is
redundant
it's you know and I apologize they don't
have that cheat in front of me but I
think the voluntary thing could apply to
any of them and once that threshold's
met then we have to Define which type of
okay yes
um representative Lane thank you
um on the mandatory use of the filing
system
you heard what we were proposing like to
phase it in but does that make sense to
you is that something from your offices
like administrative
I think makes sense or do you want to
get back to us on that or I think
whatever you decide as the the deadlines
would be fine that's your policy
decision so
but we'll have the system
the new system up and operating and
ready to take all of them okay if that's
what you decide
just wanted to make sure we
deadline
we have another question
you mentioned that secretary Scanlon is
working on definitions
um if we come up with them because I'm
kind of should we give those to him
should we wait have a working session
with him or what would he prefer do you
know or should we get back
I'm happy to bring them to the next
meeting or meet with somebody individual
beforehand so okay whatever works best
for the committee I'm I'm not sure that
we're really quite ready okay yeah but
if he has some ideas that would be great
so um yeah because I did a couple but I
and and we understand that the Secretary
of State's office
always works very well to carry out the
policy decisions of the legislature but
we still like hearing your opinions
thank you I personally don't like fax
machines but that's me personally
how do you feel about a 12 point font
Deputy Hennessey no
thank you thank you very much
uh we have some time
uh does anyone else want to that's what
that's about to ask okay is there anyone
else any members of the public that have
some thoughts they would like to share
with us would be interested to hear them
if not that's fine too
okay I'm not seeing a rush to the
microphone
if you'd like to step up to the
microphone even if you're being nice you
have to do it from the microphones
people at home okay nice that you are
someone's saying something nice we
really want them on right yes definitely
yeah if you if you could you know hook
it up and put your hand in the Bible
so to repeat myself I'm very
appreciative of what you're doing Bob
Perry the counter Stratford
um
this might be a mod the give and take is
terrific so
um I'm very appreciative of what you're
doing well thank you for your thoughts
uh thank you
it's it's my view that with a small
group like that the point is to have a
coherent discussion and I think we're
achieving that without the formality
that's typical and I would say needed in
a full committee meeting and we'll
continue to do it this way as long as it
works on this subcommittee
thank you again
it's a testament to the chairman and the
person who picked the chairman oh
absolutely
oh well if you don't have a sense of
humor life is a lot harder
are there any other topics that we think
it's worth discussing that that we need
to discuss today
we don't have to stay until 12.
I'm good in fact I have somebody wants
to meet at 11 45 so I'd love it if we
pieced out okay so I'm going to
reiterate what I said at the beginning
of the meeting because I like
reiterating because most people don't
well never mind we'll won't go there
about how often people listen but anyway
I'm going to schedule our next meeting
for two weeks from today
that'll be the 13th
uh and I'm going to schedule one more
meeting after that not necessarily the
final meeting but another meeting for
the 27th
and
I think
we've had this is our fourth meeting
I think so
so we've had a lot of opportunity to
discuss this and find the areas of
agreement
oh don't threaten me with a good time
they were very nice and explained what
the delay was and um and they're working
on it okay and that would work well for
us because then the meeting after that
we could start maybe aiming towards what
a report would look like
and I'm going to say it one more time
because I think it's important
I I think we're all agreed we're looking
for the air well agreed we're looking
for the areas of agreement that we can
pursue
and that we think our colleagues will
also agree with
all right so
two meetings at least
and we'll start to think about
generating a report
that it'll be the same time 10 A.M
Tuesday the 13th and the 27th
that work for everybody
yep thank you okay thank you Mr chairman
okay in the absence of uh
desire for further discussion I will
adjourn this meeting at
foreign